始まります これからテーマをちょこっと変えて
感情について勉強します
で さらに難しくなりますけど
感情って何なのかという勉強
感情は心に刺激を与えるんです
この刺激はエネルギーになるんです
生きるためのエネルギーですよね
だからこれは自己発生で
我々はエネルギーを作るんです
感情ということで そのエネルギーで生きて
さらに感情の刺激を与える
だから生きるということは
感情で心に刺激を与えることだから
いくらでもエネルギーがあるんです
感情のエネルギーは 感情があると心が刺激しちゃって
エネルギーが生まれてきて
じゃあ生きってみようかなと
生きってみようかなって何するのかというと
刺激を与えることするんです
するとまたエネルギーが生まれるんです
では生きてみようかなと
で また刺激を与える だから生きるということは
ご飯を食べたり 歩いたり
仕事をしたり 本を読んだり
遊んだりすることだから
まあそういうものをすることは全部心に刺激を与えます
無限にエネルギーはあります
自己発生だからね このように感情は生きる衝動になっているんです
しかし これは炭火の上に歩くような人生です
これで無限大のエネルギーがあって無限大に生きるかということは
これはありえないんです
随分短命になって死んでしまっちゃうんです
あらゆることで不幸になるんです
不幸になっても それはまた刺激になって
また踏ん張ってしまうんですね
結局は悪循環ですけど
だからまあ死んでしまっちゃって
早くも で また不幸なところに行ったりして
悪循環になるんです 仏教用語で皆様よく知っているアーサヴァ
汚さという言葉があります
なじみ深い意味は煩悩ですね
煩悩というのはよく知っていると思います
しかし 私は物知り屋さんの反対を打ち切って
この語を感情と訳するんです
私は煩悩に感情という訳するのはもうかなりもう嫌がられてはいますけど
私はやっぱり感情 煩悩ではなくて
いつでも感情という言葉を使っているのです
煩悩はたくさんありません
千五百十ですね が 千五百煩悩と呼ぶんです
いわゆる感情っていうのはたくさんあるわけじゃなくて
もうギリギリまで分析してみても
だいたい千五百ぐらいですよ
これはアビダンマという仏教の三蔵経だからね
三蔵の説の一つはアビダンマなんですね
そちらの 2番目の本はヴィパッサカラナといって
そちらでこういうクンダラというヴィパッサーナっていうのは
それほど面白くないものの分析という
大事なところを分析して終わったところで
いくつか残っちゃったんです
このあとしりの分析するところで
こういう感じ 煩悩のことを分析してあるんです
クンダラというのはスモールマターズという意味なんですね
メインテーマではないんです
次に善不善の問題を考えましょう
感情は今まで私が煩悩は感情で煩悩は不善なんですけど
でも仏教は物事を分析する場合は
この善不善という 2つに分けちゃうんです
で 千五百十の煩悩は感情は不善です
そこで仏教の分析方法によると
仏教にはいろいろ分析方法があります
例えば 今ちょっと公式で言ったんですけど
例えば A という現象があるとしますと
そうするとマイナスとプラス A という 2つがあるんだと
あるいは A という現象がマイナス A とプラス A と
プラスでもマイナスでもならない A という 3つあるんだと
プラスマイナス A と書けないんです
プラス数字ではシンボルありますけどね
プラスマイナスというシンボルが
これ この方程式で使えないんです
マイナスAがあってプラスAがあって
マイナスもプラスもという記号をつけられない
いわゆる価値判断できないAという現象もあるんだと
同じ現象ですけど そういう風なこの分析があって
シンプルですよ だから感情も1500あるならばあるはずですが
数字の遊びではないので
このような分析はありません
と言ったのは 例えば不善感情が 1510あるならば
善感情も 1510でなければいけません
そうすると 善でも不善でもない感情も 1510なくてはならないんです
しかし そういう風なリストは作ってないんです
ただ数字で遊んでいるわけでもないんだから
このすっごい頭を使って
この大事な役に立つように
特に修行に役に立つように
仏教の心理学の分析があるんです
だから この普通の論理ではなかなか理解できないというかね
大変ですけど  ただ単純シンプルで論理的に考えても
1500ぐらいの感情があって
エネルギーがあって生きているならば
それが不善であるならば
これ善に入れ替えたっても何の損もないんです
そうするとまた 1500ありますから
良い感情は 欲しいという感情は
だから 喜怒哀楽を捨てて智慧に合うっていうのはとんでもないものを知らない人々の話で
心理学を知っている人の話じゃないんです
これってアビダンマのを参考に
このクサラダンマ アクサラダンマ
アッビャーガタダンマという
このダンマっていうのは物事現象ですね
クサラ善不善 判断できない善現象という風にね
3つに分けるんです それはダンマ心理的な人の分け方なんです
それはまあ 仏教学だから私より詳しいと思います
次に心の良い刺激 今まで我々が与えられたのは危険で自己破壊する刺激なんですね
それで生きているんですから
だったら逆の感情ないのかと
自己破壊ではなくて 自分を成長してくれる
感情っていうのはあるんです
だから煩悩イコール感情という単語はそこと曖昧なんです
心の刺激で刺激で生きているから
破壊的堕落的刺激の代わりに成長的
肯定的刺激を与える これって当たり前なんでしょうに
反論することできんでしょうに
怒りは破壊的ならね そちらの反対の破壊的でない
生産的で能率も上がって肯定的な別な感情を与えればいいでしょうに
そんなのはあるものかの人は知りません
問題は 我々はそんな感情はあるのかと
喜怒哀楽以外は 怒りや欲以外は何かあるのかとわからないんですよ
わからないんだから ただもうないと言っている
目が見えない人は色がない
美はないと言っていることと同じなんです
だから我々は目が見えない状態でいるんだから
もう美しい絵が描けないんですね
本当は目で世界を楽しむ
耳で世界を楽しむよりは
目で楽しむ方が楽でしょ
耳で音を喜ぼうと思ったらそれほどないですからね
喜べる音っていうのは
でも目で見て 目で見て楽しくなろうかなと思ったら
すごい簡単でしょ ものすごい簡単
しかし 生まれつき目が見えない人にとっては
残念なことにこの楽な楽しみが全部カットされます
それで私たちは悪い悪の感情しか知りませんので
すごい大胆にあるあの幸福な世界はもうカット遮断されています
ですから ブッダは怒りの不善刺激に対して布団があると説く
身体不信ですね お釈迦様は例えば怒りの感情があります
それはみんな知っている
これは自己破壊 もうあんた方は感情を変えてくださいと
こういう感情にと言ったところで言ってもわからないんですね
経験したことがないんだから
目が見えない状態でいるんだから
だからむさぼりではなくて
布団はどうでしょうかと
そうすると なんとなく微妙にわかるんです
あ 欲をなくすことをやると
よく知ってるんだからね
そこで欲をなくすとすると
あのエネルギーがわかってくるんです
初めて味わってくるんです
そこで引っかかって どんどんどんどん布団の方向へ進んでいけばいいんです
あれ たとえで言えば あの
何でしたっけ？サラッといいますね
あれは理性なく いい加減に感情でサラッとは同意してますからね
まあ取ったりしちゃうと
あれ 時々押したりもしますよ
それからぴったり過ぎちゃう
もうどうにもならないでしょ
本当は箱の中で綺麗に取るならば終わりまで取れますよ
何のこともなく 楽々に
これ付いちゃうと もうどうにもならない
それで でも微妙にヒントがあるでしょ？ものすごい微妙なんですよ
さらっていうのはすごく細いんだから
そこで指先の感覚を微妙に使って
あれ触ってみるんですよ
ある方向へ触ってみると
何も感じない その逆方向に触ってみるんです
触ってみると 微妙なところで引っかかるんです
そこから引っ張っちゃえばもう
また楽々 そういうことで
我々はもう貪瞋痴しか知らないんだから
お釈迦様は不という否定形だけちょこっと入れて
あの微妙なところだけ教えてるんです
お釈迦様が頭悪いんだから単語をわからなかったってことじゃないんです
誰よりも頭が良かったんだから
ローバの代わりにア入れてアローバというんです
これだけでもブッダがいかに智慧の達人かということがわかるんですよ
他の宗教みたいにアイやアイやとかね
アイラアイラアイヤというのが
結局はイヤイヤで終わっちゃいますからね
そんなもう教えじゃなくて
人間の心の状況を知り尽くして
人間は知ったことはないんだと
これはもう生まれつき目が見えない人の状態でいるんだから
美はわからないんだと
美について説法したっても意味がないんだとよくわかって
貪瞋痴の代わりに不貪不瞋不痴と
いつでもそういう論理でいくんですよ
全現象に対する不全現象
クサラダンマアクサラダンマ
それが仏教の論理学なんです
良い感情は破壊的ではない
幸福を司るんです 怒りは自分を破壊するならば短命にするならば
怒りの反対だったらどうでしょうか
反対わかりません だから怒りを消すだけで十分です
それでなんとなく糸が見えてくるんです
そこからどんどんサララットと同じが引っ張っていればいいんです
で どこまででも幸福になります
結構なんか若者とか誰か若者の気を利いているかどうか分かりませんだけど
学生で神通やら超能力からそんなのは自分は認めませんとかね
まあ若い子供だからそれでいいんだけど
そこはもうそういう単純な話じゃないんです
悪の感情を消していくと
どこまででも成長していく
肉体に依存することはもうどうでもいいってことになるんです
だから神通なんかというのはとっても簡単に見せてです
天眼であろうか 天児であろうか
そんなのはそれほど大したことはない
しかし うまいことに目が見えない人に絵画の説明をして酷い目にあうことだけはしません
これは 5億円の値打ちのある絵画だよと目が見えない人にあげたらどうしますかね
あの人は触ってみても何にも取れない
あんた頭が悪いんじゃないの？触ったって何のことないでしょ
オイルペイントだったらギザギザギザギザ感じるだけでね
面白くないんです 私もそういう
まあ一般世界ではすごく評価されている絵画なんか見て
これ触ったら超気持ち悪いでしょうと
だから触らせてくれないでしょうね
触るもんか そんなのは
そういうことです だから
この普通の俗世間で幸福になるっていうのは
こんなのはもうちょろいんですよ
もう何でもできる もう肉体なんかはもう全然もう関係ない
ダンマサンガニというアビダンマテキストから一部紹介します
これからこの善の感情
一部たくさんあります
あと 悪の感情というのは1500にしていますけど
まあまあ それも分析上で
本当はとんちんちみすなんです
1500煩悩といっても
しかし もう微妙に分析できちゃって
人間に作ることは可能といえる
一切の悪の感情だそうではないか
いわゆるいい尽くそうではないかというところで
1514になっちゃったんです
一人一人に全部ある じゃないんです
あれは言い尽くしてるんです
で まとめたら誰にでもあるものっていうのは
基本的な柱は三つ 貪瞋痴
三毒です だから見事に三毒というんです
それで三毒という三つにしてしまえば
善の方が良い感情が数が大きいんです
が 千五百以上は少ないです
例えばピーティというのは喜
スッカ 楽 チッタセイガタっていうのは統一性
精神的に統一して落ち着いている
サッダー 確信 自信がある
曖昧で中途半端じゃないんです
ヴィリヤ 精進する 活発的なんです
サティ 気づき ぼけーとしていないんで
いつでも物事は知っていると
サマーディというのはまた統一
落ち着いているということで
パンニャー 智慧があるんです
ヒリ 慚愧 オッタッパ 疑ですね
慚愧っていうのは これはいつでも説明しますから
ヒリっていうのはもう悪いことを嫌がっちゃうんですね
貪瞋痴は嫌い 気持ち悪いと
貪瞋痴 貪瞋痴って何もしません
気持ち悪い 恥ずかしい
それで貪瞋痴で何かするのは
これはもう不幸になるんだからね
やばいと このことですね
慚愧っていうのは アローガ
不貪 不瞋 不痴 それからアナビッジャ
異常欲 異常の怒り  否定形ですね
異常欲がない  ああ そうですね
否定形なんです そういう風なあるんです
我々も育てようと思えば
喜怒哀楽の代わりにいっぱいありますよ
喜怒哀楽の代わりに精進ぐらいすればどうですかね
怠けていないで 喜怒哀楽の代わりに物事に気づいてればどうですかね
喜は入った  え？ ピーティが入る
うん ピーティ 喜びを 喜びを感じたらどうでしょうか
どんなものにも喜びを感じますよ
これは私はこのよくあのユーモアを持ってね
なんか冗談を言う性格も
例えば何でもちょこっと冗談言ってからかう人だったら
人に会っても何か面白いこと言っちゃうでしょうね
楽しいんですよ  ムディターとは違うんですか？ それは別な種類なんですよ
喜びも１本ではないんです
例えば喜と楽という場合でも
あの喜っていうのは どちらかというと精神的なところで
楽っていうのは肉体的にも感じる楽というね
ムディターっていうのはもうちょこっと別なものなんですね
ムディターも 2つありますよ
ソフネスということと
あの まあ優しいということなんですけどね
他人のことをあ 良かったって思うことがある
その場合 ジヒキシャーヤに入りますけどね
すごい微妙に分類されています
それからここら辺勉強してほしいんです
カーヤパッサでチッタパッサって
良い感情っていうのは
この 落ち着きなんですね
なんか普通我々は体と心を重いと感じていますよ
パッサッダっていうのはなんか軽くなって落ち着いてくるんです
そこでカーヤっていうのは体というよりも
この感覚の方なんです
感覚と心が軽くなるんです
肉体はどうでもいいんですよ
肉体の重さは変わりません
だからね でも肉体 肉体は心で動かしてますから
心はすごく軽くなると
感情も感覚も気持ちも軽くなると
肉体はすごい勝手についてきます
それから同じ文章だから省略したんです
あのカーヤラフタ チッタラフタ
気持ちと心の軽さ 軽い
それからムドゥター あのムディターと言ったところが
こちらでムドゥターと言うんです
ムディターっていうのは慈悲喜捨の単語だから
そこはそちらに入れておいて
こちらはムドゥター 柔らかさ
柔らかい気持ちも心もすごいソフト
で カンマンニャタ カーヤカンマンニャタ
チッタカンマンニャタ
カンマンニャタっていうのは
この 何と言いますか  suitable というね
もう適当 適切状態になって
もう何でもできる状態になっているというね
心と感情 感覚がもうすごい調子いいところになるんですよ
最高の調子になっちゃって
何でもできそうという
それはカンマンジャタなんです
次にパルンジャタ これは辞書では連達性とあったんだから
そのままがもう真似たんです
パルンジャタっていうのは
即席の単語で言えば 経験があってもう慣れてるっていうことなんです
プロっていうことなんです
だからプロみたいな状態で
心と気持ちが 感覚がまあ揃ってくるんです
プロも何でもできると
で 次にウッジカタ カーヤウッジカタ
チッタウッジカタ これは単直性でしたっけ
うん いわゆる優柔不断じゃないっていうこと
しっかりなんです 寄り道はなく
しっかりと生きてられるんです
だから私たちは仕事をすると
なんですっごく疲れるかというと
これがないんだからなんです
これ全部ないんだからなんです
で 例えばウッジカタ この単直性なければなんか気持ちが揺らぐんでしょうね
あっちこっちあっち それで時間がかかるんでしょう
それで能率が下がっちゃうんです
次にサンパジャンニャ
こういうサンパジャンニャっていうのは
このサティのヴィパッサナー瞑想する場合は
あの教えることはできないんだけど
それもついてこないとダメなんです
サティとサンパジャンニャっていうのはセットなんです
ただ サティだけで気づくだけで智慧が出てこないんです
だからサティは英語でマインドフルネス
サンパジャンニャはアウェアネスなんです
アウェアネスという なんか難しい
これ教えるのは 例えばこの痛みを感じる
瞑想する場合は痛みを感じる
痛み 痛み 痛み 痛みっていうだけだったらもうサティだけなんで何にもなりません
あ 痛みだなと それをなんとなく微妙に理解していくんです
それがサンパジャンニャなんです
だから確認しながらその現象を理解してほしい
微妙ですけど それでどんどん智慧が開いていくんです
それからサマタ サマタっていうのはみんな知ってる
サマタですね 集中力 ヴィパッサナーっていうのはみんな知ってる
もう観ですね 観察する能力
サティですね アビッケパっていうのは混乱なしっていう
混乱はない もう心はすごく揃っていて
だから最高の状況に行ってるんです
こういうのは仏教以外どこでも論述されてはないんです
これもすべてじゃないんです
いくつかだけ紹介したんです
だから私は今ただ言いたいのは一つ
ポイントは一つ 喜怒哀楽の代わりにこれやって何が悪いんですか
と 喜びがあって 楽しみがあって
活発で また心はすごく柔軟で
調子が最高に良くて 何が悪いんですかね
混乱 興奮なく ずっと冷静にいられて
まだ物事は何が起きているのかとよく知っていて
そのエネルギーはなんで悪いんでしょうかと
貪瞋痴の代わりに ただ経験したことがないんだからわからないだけ
あんたら頑張って経験しなきゃいけないんです
それで八正道のこの感情のリストに入るんでしょう
正見 正思惟 何でしたっけ？正語
なんとかなんとか ハンマーでサンマーはサンマーワーチャいろいろありますからね
八正道も入ってます だから何かわかりますかね
この智慧智慧といっても
仏教は智慧も感情のセットに入ってますよ
なぜかというとエネルギーですからね
エネルギーが生命なんですよ
ただ単にたまたま物体の中に入り込んでいるんだからといって
物体が生命じゃないんです
皆様は人間という物体になったんだから
私が人間だぞとかって思っちゃうと
輪廻転生わからなくなっちゃうんで
あんた人間じゃないんですということ
ただ生命である あるエネルギーである
この体のことを忘れちゃえばいいと
そうすると エネルギーとして流れ込んだということは非常に簡単に見えてくるんです
肉体ばっかり考えて 俺が死んだら生まれ変わるはずが
生まれ変わりませんよ
肉体は腐るだけだから
だからこのエネルギーのことを言ってるんです
このエネルギーは貪瞋痴という恐ろしい自己破壊の道で
苦から苦へ 苦から苦へと流れているんです
貪瞋痴がないんだから
これが別な方向へ入れ替えるんです
だから仏教の道に入ったら
普通の人よりは桁違いに元気になるんです
前のエピソードでは 田舎のお坊さんにイギリス人もう裁判までもう何のことなく茶化しちゃって話しちゃってね
しかし 自分に対して罰を与えることもできないという
すごく智慧があるんです
でも その当時のお坊さんたちと
それからあと独立になるまでっていたお坊さんたちっていうのは
もう信じられないほど頭が良かったんです
みんなもう これで仏教の場合
お釈迦様の歯をね スリランカのもう国民の国を守ってくれる
もうもう聖なる宝物だとみんな思っているんだから
命かけて守っていて イギリス軍人にも国全体取られちゃったら戦災産奪って持っていくでしょ
だからあらゆる宝物を持っていったんですけど
これだけ見つからないんです
イギリス人知ってます
これはもう この人々はもう野蛮人たちだから
この儀式 儀礼 もう毎日の器
器 お供え あれやこれやと必ずやっているんだと
だからすぐバレるんだよ
どこにあるのかと それを盗みたかったんです
なぜかというと 植民地になったんだけど
制御できない 誰もイギリスの王様を王様だと思ってないんです
イギリス人のいい法律は全然あまり相手に気にしない
だからって戦わない人を殺せないでしょうね
国民殺したって政治にならないんだからね
すぐズズの種でインド人と違うやり方
そういうことで まあこれイギリスにとってイギリスに持っていける
いけばスリランカ人はイギリスを拝むしかないんだぞと
で見つからなかったんです
ずっと調べたんです どこに隠ったのかと
スリランカ人みんな知ってるんです
あるところは そこであるもう隠れた小さなお寺で
これを隠しておいて 信者さんはちゃんと昔からの伝統的にこの仏教にあの仏様の範囲やっている
この儀式あります それは必ずやってるんです
3回 退屈な回 3回と 5回で 5回 1日
これが派手な音なんですけど
お世話したりする このお寺で
まあじゃあ我々普通にやってますよと
お寺だからいいのおかしいんだと言って調べるんです
どう調べてるも何もない
もう騙されて帰っちゃうんです
お寺にいた住職さんがこの衣にこちらにつけてあった
どうやって見つかるでしょうか
だからお釈迦様はいるんだからちゃんとやってます
それもいつでも着ていたわけじゃないと思いますけど
誰か来るのお坊さん あ
挨拶に行かなくちゃと
すぐあの衣を着ているんです
だから衣見たって見たってもないでしょうしね
こうやってこうシャツとかなんとか着てるわけじゃないでしょうに
調べるところはないんです
だからすごくもう国からはもう動かせませんということね
いくらなんでも勝てるでしょ
何の戦いもなく命懸けますよ
死にますよってのはないんです
今イラクで起きてるような感じで
ないんだけど ちゃんと知恵を持って
それにはちょっとヒューマーがないとできませんよ
だから仏陀にももうあれほどもう尊敬しているのに
あれほど宮殿みたいな建物を作って
もう立ち入り禁止やボディチェックするわ
もう大変なのに もう中に入る場合もすごい気配りがありまして
なのにこれ衣にも着てない衣につけるということはね
失礼ではなく 罰が当たるのではなく
もちろんあのお坊さんがね
お釈迦様もね 悪い時は悪いということ
あの占いでは星占い向こうありますから
あの時期があるんですね
不幸になる時期 お釈迦様にもこういう時期でしょうとか何とか言いながらもつけたでしょうね
これはそれ失礼だ そんなこと言ってやる場合でしょ
お釈迦様にも今は悪い時期だからね
まあ苦労しなくちゃいけないんだよ
だからそう言われるぐらいの余裕ですかね
だから この人間というのは
喜と楽前の時にあったような感じで
すごく喜んでいる感じで生き方をすると
不幸になっても何のことないんですよ
例えばお医者さんのところに行ったところで
あれこれと検査されちゃって
もう苦しくて苦しくてたまらなかったと
じゃあ苦しかった まあ嫌だではなくて
殺されそうになったな
お医者さんにとかね あの人忙しいんだから
まあ殺す前にやっとかもうもう出してくれたと
いう冗談でしょうに 別に医者は殺すわけじゃないし
でも自分とは苦しがったんだからね
だからどんな状況でも
ちょこっとこのヒューマーがあれば
それが理性から出てくるんですよ
それも感情でしょうに
喜んじゃうと笑っちゃうとエノキでしょ
だからそうやって決してこの貪瞋痴の世界を捨てたんだからと
苦しくなるわけじゃないんです
やる気がなくなるわけじゃなくて
ものすごく誰にも計算できない状態でやる気が出てくるのです
すごく明るくなるんです
で 普通は我々にない経験もしない刺激なのです
今説明したリストは 徐々に育てなくてはならないものです
どこまででも心は成長する
成功と幸福を収めるエネルギーです
だから良い感情っていうのは
どこまででも我々は成長させてくれるんです
幸福にしてくれるんです
知恵 理解なども入っているから
理性の敵ではありません
例えば仏教は知恵さえも感情でしてますよ
ということは 知恵もエネルギーなんです
ということで 全感情は理性の敵ではありません
不善感情は理性の仇敵なんです
理性が我々を守ってくれるのです
それで感情のバランスって何なのかと
悪感情のバランスではありません
悪感情のバランスはじゃないんで
これは捨てなさい まず
それなら 悪者のデパートになるだけ
悪い感情の適当に怒って
適当に欲張って 適当に嫉妬して
適当に憎しんで 適当に恨んでいればどうなるんですかね
ただの悪者のデパートでしょ
たとえ適当適当といっても
だから決して悪感情のバランスはダメです
悪感情は捨てるんです
善感情のバランスのことなんです
これについてはすごく書いてますよ
テキストでは 結構大変です
人は分かりやすいところから成功への訓練するので
いっぺんにすべての善を実践できません
善感情たくさんあるんだけど
いっぺんにもう分かったこともないし
知ったこともないし 経験したこともないんだから
あのサイレンラップのような感じですごく微妙なところから始めなくちゃいけないんです
それでどんどんどんどんどんどん成長していかなくちゃいけないんです
だからそちらにはバランス論が成り立つんです
善感情のバランス論 例えば最初に怒らないということだけを何度か繰り返したと
あ 怒らない方が楽やと
勝ちやと そこでその人は怒らないことをどんどんやっちゃうでしょうね
怒らないことだけやっても
欲張らないことはまた欠けてますね
それをやらないと それで怒らないことやっていると
あ やっぱりこれだけではダメだ
欲張らないこともやらなくちゃって
それが始まるんです それもやっても
やっぱり頭で考えること意味がないんだ
頭を良くしなくちゃいけない
で 次の感情に行くんです
そういうことでバランスということが出てくるんです
一つ二つだけの偏るだけ偏ると他はの善がなくなる
文章がおかしくなってます
一つ二つだけに偏ると
例えば一つ二つの善感情に偏って
私はこれしかやりませんよとかね
他のものはバランスが整う
もう崩れちゃうんです
インターネットで質問がありましたけど
あの なんで文章があるんでしょうかと
気持ち悪いんじゃないかとかね
友達に仏教 あなた方の仏教は紹介することはできませんがとかね
私はブッダの教えはすごくいいものだと思っていますという文章あったんですよ
それっていうのは ものすごい極端に頭が偏っているという
ブッダの教えを気に入った
他全部ダメ 何やと これ
やっぱりそういう人々も徐々徐々に徐々に徐々に成長していかなくちゃいけない
私の頭に来たのを頭に来たってのは
これ浮かんだ考え方は
あの この人って何言うのかと
世界に文学とかね 美とかね
作ったのは誰でしょうかと
インドを土を掘ったら出てくるのは何なのかと
それ仏教美でしょう みんな元気ですからね
仏教とは 楽しくてもうすごいんです
いろんなもの お坊さんとかね
あの砂漠でどうですかね
天国作ってやったんですよ
どんな宗教の人を見てやりできない
それは気持ち悪くて何やと
より偏っている まあ本人も仏教の言葉をいくつかいくつか勉強していくと
これは良かったことだ
それだけ良かったというではないんで
まあそういうところから始めて
もっともっと緩やかな心で
大きな心で もっと柔軟な心で
だからまあはっきり極端に答えるならば
仏像やらそういうものを見ると
気持ち悪いというのは
おそらく洞窟で住んでいる人でしょうと
日本ではなくて 日本ではどこへ行ったってもたら見えますけどね
その方の友達はおそらく洞窟人生でしょうね
だから ただ気づいたんだからそう書いたんですけど
やっぱり逆から見るとやっぱり偏っているんだっていうことですね
では 仏像のことを仏教で見たら
それまた偏っているんでしょうね
そういうことで 結構進まなくちゃいけないんですよ
仏典では大変注意するところです
この全能感情をバランスを整えてください
この全能感情の場合 バランスというのはこのあの均等にすることなんです
すべて良いものだから
栄養バランスとは違います
栄養のバランスというのは
何でも同じ量を取ることじゃないんですけどね
この全感情の場合はすべて均等になった方がよろしいのです
統一性情だけ進むと智慧が減るんでしょうに
例えば瞑想する人々でも
何か一つだけに集中して
もうずっとそればっかりやっちゃうと気分が良くなりますよ
だって何も知らなくなっちゃうんです
情は統一性を育てます
例えば呼吸瞑想でもしちゃうと
それだけ見られるんですけど
知恵が出てこないんです
知恵が出てこないってことは
仏教の人もできなくなっちゃうんです
だからと言って情がいらないかというと
必要なんです 最初に情を統一して育てた人は
それは適当なレベルに来たら
次欠けてるものを育てなくちゃいけないんです
そこで信が強くなると
また同じ結果なんですね
信というのは信仰で確信でもうありがたがる
理解する あーよかった
よかったとか そうなってくるとよかったばっかりで何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
理解能力 分析能力だけ強くなると
そういう理解能力 分析能力の全感情なんです
理解能力 分析能力だけになってくるとどうなるかというと
落ち着きがなくなっちゃうんです
情が消えてしまうんです
精進だけ進むとまた同じ結果
精進ばっかりする もうとにかくやってやると
元気で混乱しちゃうんです
情がなくなっちゃうんです
だから たとえ戦場でも偏ってはならないっていうこと
です でも混乱しても大丈夫ですよ
例えば精進ばっかしやってやってやっても
とにかくやみくもにやったと
そうなると あるところでカチンと止まるんです
そこでアドバイスしますよ
じゃあ次にこれをやってくださいと
あれは無駄にはなりません
戦場だから で どうせ人間というのは腰が重すぎだから
口だけでやるつもりですけど
本当はやりたくないしね
何でもかんでも だから私はよく言うことは
とにかくやみくもにやってください
まず 死ぬほどの勢いでやってくださいと
それが全てっていう意味じゃないんです
死ぬほどの勢いでサティヴィパッサナーやっていると
ある程度で進んではいきますよ
そこでバランス崩れるところまで待っていて
はい 次にこれをやってくださいと言うんです
あんたこれ欠けてるんだと
そもそもそもそも言うんです
気づき サティだけ進むのも良くない
サンパジャニャも必要なんです
サティだけ進んじゃうと
ただマンネリになっちゃって
やってるだけで終わっちゃうんです
サンパジャニャってアウェアネス
何が起きているのかっていうことがないと
智慧の方に行かないという
まあだから戦場上の だからバランスというのはすごい
すごい大事なことで 全感情が発達して均等になると
生命としての次元まで破れるんです
生命が破壊するんじゃなくて
生命であることまで次元破れて超越するんです
解脱できるんです 貪瞋痴から一時的にでも離れていることができれば
その時の幸福感 清涼感
安らぎは 俗世間では決して感じることはできないのです
ちょっと一時的でも 我々は貪瞋痴から離れると
日常生活で決して味わうことのできない
すごく清涼感 幸福感が味わえるんです
これ お釈迦様のある言葉から取った文章なんですけど
この誰かが言ったのお釈迦様に
あなた贅沢にいるか あなた贅沢にいるというのは
あなたよりお釈迦様の方がすごい贅沢ではないかと
お釈迦様が言った 私は贅沢だよと言ったら
この相手の人はね なんだ
あんた住むところもなくて
裸足でご飯食べて贅沢だと言えるもんかと
だったらお釈迦様の方があなたより偉いんじゃないかと
そしたらお釈迦様がね
あんたね 無責任に喋るなよと
あんたの観念はすごい無責任だよと
では聞きますがということで
お釈迦様はまあ 公装様にたとえ 1 分でもガチャガチャガチャガチャあれこれやと妄想しないで
心で悩むことなく 何も思考することなく
肉体はあることさえも感じなく
完全に心を停止していたけますか？ 1 分だけ
言ったら その人はまあこれは生きるものには無理だと
ただ 私はね  1 分ではなくて 1 時間見ますよと
1 時間だけじゃなくて
半日見ますよ その状態で
半日だけじゃなくて  1 日中見ますよ
時々 1 週間もいますよ
完全に停止して 肉体はあることさえも感じない
何の概念もない 何の感情もなく
何の波もない 完全な平穏な状態
どうですか？と言ったら
やっぱり確かに釈さんは贅沢ですと
ということになったんです
それはお釈迦様の悟った人の境地で
俗世間でも貪瞋痴から離れた瞬間で
ものすごい心が喜びを感じるんです
幸福感を感じるんです
だから 悪の刺激っていうのは気持ち悪くても捨ててほしいんですよ
あれは悪臭を嗅いで嗅いで嗅いで
ああ 刺激だ 刺激だと言っていることと同じなんですよ
悪臭嗅いでも刺激はかもしれませんだけど
なんで美しい香りを嗅げないんですかね
悪臭嗅いではすごい激しい刺激で
もう気が失ってしまったり
倒れたりして ああ 刺激でよかったらまたもう一度嗅いでやろうという人生と
すごく美しい穏やかな香りを嗅いでいる人生って違うでしょう
悪感情は危険だが 仏教は生きる衝動を純粋な清らかなエネルギーにする方法を紹介しているんですね
だからこの悪感情は完全に取っちゃって
その代わりに素晴らしいのがやりますよということで
一旦一つテーマが終わります
まあ時間ないんだから続けてやります